Putins Krieg
Russlands Nachbarländer fühlen sich
bedroht
Russland führt seinen Angriff gegen den
Westen nicht nur mit Waffen auch mit
Worten
Sommer 2022 in Köln treffen sich
Unterstützer Putins siehe und andere
werben in Deutschland für die Politik
der russischen Regierung viele
verteidigen auch den Angriff auf die
Ukraine
ZDF Zoom fragt wer sind die Drahtzieher
der Propaganda was sind ihre Ziele
[Musik]
immer häufiger ist Deutschlands Ziel
russischer Propaganda in den sozialen
Medien bei öffentlichen Veranstaltungen
sogar in der Politik mit Propaganda
versucht Russland Einfluss zu gewinnen
Meinungen in Deutschland zu beeinflussen
Stephen broschat ist datenanalyst seit
Jahren unterstützt ihr Polizei und
Staatsanwaltschaften bei der
Internetrecherche für ZDF Zoom
analysiert er pro russische Propaganda
sucht nach einflussreichen Accounts bei
seinen Recherchen im Netz stößt ihr
immer wieder auf die gleichen influencer
also wenn wir uns mal die
deutschsprachigen Propagandisten
anschauen dann fallen drei Akteure auf
allen voran Alina Lipp an den Alina Lipp
ist ja eine junge Frau Ende 20 war
früher auch
bei den Grünen politisch aktiv und sie
kooperiert mit Thomas rulpa Thomas Röper
ist bereits während der corona-pandemie
mit verschwörungstheoretischen Inhalten
aufgefallen und dann haben wir noch
einen dritten Akteur Sergej Filbert sehr
gefilbert ist vor allem im
russischsprachigen Raum sehr sehr aktiv
sehr gleich Filbert ist gleich mit zwei
Kanälen auf Youtube unterwegs einer
nennt sich druschbar was übersetzt
Freundschaft bedeutet
die Internetseite von Thomas Röper heißt
der anti-spiegel
und auch eine junge Frau ist im
russischen propaganda-netz
allgegenwärtig ihr Name Alina
warum finanziert ihr diesen Mord an der
Zivilbevölkerung setzt euch dafür ein
dass diese Waffenlieferung aufhören
Alina Lipp wird 1993 geboren ihr Vater
ist Russe die Mutter Deutsch sie hat in
Deutschland studiert machte ihren Master
in Nachhaltigkeit von 2015 bis 2020 ist
sie Mitglied bei den Grünen mit ihrer
Mutter nimmt sie an corona-protesten
Teil im Internet nennt sie sich
friedensjournalistin und verbreitet seit
2019 russische Kriegspropaganda
die Menschen fangen vor meinen Augen an
zu heulen und erzählen wir von diesen
Schandtaten die die ukrainischen Nazis
an ihm verüben
frontbesuch in den zahllosen
Internet-Videos Alina lips lebt die
russische Propaganda Putins Truppen
verklärt zu heilsbringern
die Russen nehmen gerade so ganz platt
gesagt den Nazis die Waffen weg dadurch
junge Frau handelt
wirkt in erster Linie erstmal harmlos
und sie wirkt überzeugt von dem was sie
tut und das macht sie natürlich
insgesamt sehr sehr glaubwürdig das ist
ein riesen Unterschied zu anderen
Propagandisten wo ja dann auch viel viel
mehr Schärfe in der Rhetorik zu finden
ist dass sie hier eher weich
herüberkommt
[Musik]
Alina Lipp lebt inzwischen sogar im
russisch besetzten Donbass
ihrem telegram-kanal Neues aus Russland
Folgen knapp 200.000 Menschen
die ukrainische Armee wird von ihr als
mördergruppe beschrieben die wahllos
jagt auf Kinder und zivile Opfer mache
Alina Lipp hat beste Kontakte in die
Schaltzentrale russischer macht
Schnappschüsse auf einem ihrer Accounts
zeigen Sie mit Maria sacharowa der
Sprecherin des russischen
Außenministeriums und eine der
einflussreichsten Frauen Russlands
Danilo Höpfner kennt diese Frauen er
arbeitet für die Friedensbewegung
Memorial die 2022 mit dem
Friedensnobelpreis ausgezeichnet wurde
in Russland werden Mitglieder von
Memorial bedroht und verhaftet
natürlich das ist schon aus Seiten des
Kreml ein gelungenes Produkt wie man es
gern haben möchte er eine attraktive
junge Frau der man gern zu sieht der man
gerne zuhört das spricht der viele
Menschen auch an sie kann in der Tat
reden aber inhaltlich ist das so obskur
was sie da von sich gibt sie tritt in
Uniform der der russischen
Armee auf sie mit dem z-zeichen und
verkauft sich dann als Journalistin in
ihren Beiträgen das ist unabwürdig
gegen Alina lebt ermittelt inzwischen in
Deutschland die Staatsanwaltschaft der
Vorwurf die Verbreitung von
Kriegspropaganda konkret der Belohnung
oder Billigung von Straftaten auf nahezu
allen großen Internetplattformen ist
Alina Lipp vertreten
Auftritte wie auf Telegramm machen sie
zu den wichtigsten deutschsprachigen
Vertreterinnen russischer
Kriegspropaganda wir möchten von ihr
wissen ob sie vom russischen Starter für
bezahlt wird eine Interviewanfrage wird
abgelehnt aus Zeitgründen schriftlich
erhalten wir eine Antwort von ihrem
Webteam das Alina Lipp unterstützt
Alina erhält keine Bezahlung oder
Unterstützung von Stellen der Russischen
Föderation
sie finanziert sich ausschließlich durch
freiwillige Spenden und durch die
familiäre Unterstützung ihrer Eltern
[Musik]
eine Aussage die wir nicht überprüfen
können sicher ist hingegen dass sich
Alina Lipp kompromisslos in den Dienst
des Kreml stellt
Frau Lipp darf ihren Kanälen treibt hat
mit Journalismus nichts aber euch
überhaupt nichts zu tun dass es
klassische Propaganda und jetzt
funktioniert das überall ein junges
weibliches Gesicht im Sinne des Kreml
das ist Frau Lipp
zu den Mitstreitern Alina Lipps gehört
der Russlanddeutsche online-aktivist
Sergej Victor Filbert sie kennen sich
Betrieben gemeinsam ein youtube-projekt
als 17-Jähriger wandert Hilbert mit
seiner Familie aus Sibirien nach
Deutschland ein Russland hält er bis
heute die Treue
es ist nicht der Russland Verschulden
als Land das ist passiert ist das ist
Russland Reaktion und wenn sie in China
Fragen oder im Indien dann sagen sie ja
die haben die gleiche Meinung das Westen
hat Russland provoziert hat zwei Brüder
Volker erstmal im Ukraine auf sich
aufeinander gehetzt dass sie sich töten
übrigens das Töten von in diesem
Bürgerkrieg haben nicht die donezka und
nicht nur Menschen begann sondern
ukrainische Einheiten und die Nazis
Russland mache vieles richtig sagt
tilbert in Deutschland engagiert er sich
seit Jahren für die deutsch-russische
Freundschaft organisierte bereits 2016
sogenannte friedensfahrten von Berlin
nach Moskau im russischen
Staatsfernsehen tritt ihr zusammen mit
dem nato-kritiker Rainer Rothfuss auf
heute ein afd-funktionär
Sergej Filbert betreibt den
YouTube-Kanal golloss Germany die Stimme
Deutschlands er nimmt
nachrichtenbeiträge aus dem deutschen
Fernsehen kommentiert sie fügt seine
eigene Meinung hinzu und übersetzt alles
ins Russische
mit 250 Millionen videoabrufen gehört
sein Kanal zu den Reichweiten stärksten
Russlands
Steven Broschart hat den Kanal für ZDF
Zoom ausgewertet
[Musik]
filberts Filme seien einseitig und
zeichneten ein verzerrtes
Deutschlandbild
das Projekt zu gol aus Germani was ich
ja primär an russischsprachige Menschen
richtet es existiert ja schon länger er
selber positioniert sich zwar mit diesem
Projekt als ja reine reiner über
Übersetzer
politischer deutscher reden aber wenn
man sich eben dort die Inhalte anschaut
dann ist ganz klar wir haben hier eine
eindeutig kontra westliche
Positionierung
Interviews im deutschen Fernsehen gibt
Sergej Filbert nur sehr selten lange
haben wir uns um ein Gespräch mit ihm
bemüht wir möchten von ihm wissen was
sind seine Gründe warum betreibt ihr pro
russische Propaganda
wenn man alle transatlantische Aktionen
sich mal ehrlich anschaut egal für was
für ein Zweck die denken die man kreativ
Diktator stürzen am Ende gab es immer
was Krieg und das wollte ich verhindern
wir Geld nur heute in den deutschen
Medien als einer der wichtigen
Propagandisten des Kreml wenn ich ihn
zuhöre bin ich bin nicht mehr gar nicht
bin ich mir gar nicht sicher sehen Sie
das als Beleidigung oder sind sie es
vielleicht sogar als Kompliment und
sagen eigentlich ist das was Russland
macht richtig es ist für mich
erschreckend weil 140 Millionen Russen
sind ja nicht Putin ich habe dort
Verwandten das heißt es kann auch sein
wenn Westen jetzt noch drei Jahren
waffenliefert dass meine Verwandten
Krieg müssen uns sterben und ich will
nicht dass meine Kinder oder meine
Bekannten aus Deutschland an der
ukrainische voll gegen meinen Verwandten
kämpfen egal wer Recht hat
zweiter YouTube-Kanal heißt druschbar FM
mit knapp 23.000 Abonnenten gezeigt wird
auf dem Kanal unter anderem auch eine
sogenannte torx-sendung mit dem Namen
nato-untersuchungsausschuss einer seiner
Gäste der Verschwörungstheoretiker
Markus Fiedler mit scharfen Vorwürfen
gegen die USA sie wollen
DNA-Proben von Rüssel haben weniger von
Ukrainern ist das die Frage wozu wollen
sie das es geht hier anscheinend um
biowaffenforschung und es geht um
waffenforschung die sich nur auf eine
Idee bezieht
Vorwürfe die Filbert unkommentiert
stehen lässt Kritik an Russland
Fehlanzeige auf seinen Internetseiten
wirbt er für die deutsch-russische
Freundschaft und macht Werbung für
Russland
ich habe mir einige Sendungen angeschaut
vom sogenannten
nato-untersuchungsausschuss was ist so
ihre Motivation gewesen die NATO in der
Form zu kritisieren ich als Bürger
Deutschland muss für mich und meine
Kinder statt drei Kinder entscheiden ist
NATO für mich gut sind NATO Kriege für
mich gut sind Nathan erwartet
Erweiterung ist NATO Erweiterung für
mich gut und ich würde sagen nicht weil
wenn ich dieses Jahr meine Rechnung
nicht zahlen kann weil Russland Gas
abgab weil Deutschland Waffen der
Ukraine liefert dann weiß man das ist
falsch bei der FM ist es so durch bei FM
soll eigentlich als ja freundschaftliche
Brücke zwischen unterschiedlichen
Ländern eben dienen
wenn man sich aber mal die Inhalte
anschaut dann ja wird es eigentlich
vollkommen konterkariert denn die
Inhalte sind sehr sehr aggressiv
und Contra Westen
dass sie gegen den Westen sind zeichnet
viele der Propagandisten aus die im
Internet unterwegs sind Thomas Röper
gilt ebenfalls als ein enger Vertrauter
Alina lips gemeinsam produzieren sie
propagandaklips die auf Telegramm
Kanälen und YouTube veröffentlicht
werden Thomas Röper ist auch Buchautor
Blogger Kriegsberichterstatter hier
unterwegs in Donbass im russischen
Staatsfernsehen spricht ihr über
Deutschlands angebliche Unfreiheit
ich betreibe seit dem Verbot von Russia
Today und Sputnik in Deutschland das
letzte Portal das übrig geblieben ist
das andere Standpunkte vertritt
seit 2013 betreibt Röper die
Internetseite anti-spiegel er arbeitet
von St Petersburg aus hier verbreitet
der studierte finanzwirtschaftler
russische Propaganda leugnet
Kriegsverbrechen den Vorwurf als
Propagandist zu wirken weist Röper auf
zoomanfrage zurück und erklärt
schriftlich
es wäre schön wenn man sich mit meiner
Arbeit meinen Quellen und meinen
Argumenten auseinandersetzen würde
anstatt kampfbegriffe zu benutzen
Doktor Susanne Spahn ist Politologin sie
ist Russland Expertin und hat sich viel
mit der Arbeit russischer Propagandisten
beschäftigt das Interview mit ihr müssen
wir an einem anonymen Ort drehen immer
wieder werde sie bedroht das habe mit
ihrer Arbeit zu tun sie spricht über die
Ziele der Meinungsmacher
ich Strategie ist ja die Unzufriedenen
anzusprechen den Unmut zu schüren und
das sehen wir jetzt mit Blick auf den
ukrainekrieg sehr deutlich es werden
also Existenzängste geschürt über einen
wirtschaftlichen Niedergang Deutschlands
dann wird die Gefahr des dritten
Weltkrieges beschworen oder eines
nuklearkrieges natürlich haben die Leute
Angst die Ängste sind da und die werden
dann ganz geschickt aufgegriffen und
instrumentalisiert für politische Zwecke
wie das funktioniert zeigt ein Fall aus
Berlin aus dem Jahr 2016 russische
Staatsmedien pushen die angebliche
Vergewaltigung eines 13-jährigen
Mädchens deutsch-russischer Eltern die
Täter angeblich Südländer
es ist ein russischer propagandakuh
russlandsaußenminister Sergej lavrov
wirft den deutschen Behörden die
Vertuschung der Vergewaltigung vor ein
scharfer Vorwurf ohne Substanz
Ermittlungen der Staatsanwaltschaft
verzaubern den Fall dieser schließlich
als Fake News
[Musik]
russische Propaganda folgt einem Muster
Ängste werden geschürt das politische
System in Deutschland schlecht gemacht
im Netz und auf der Straße
dahinter steckt ein Kalkül vermuten
Experten die Bilder von öffentlichen
Veranstaltungen lieferten Munition für
die Propaganda im Netz und in den
russischen Medien Leverkusen juni 2022
gemeinsam mit rechtsradikalen machen
russische putinfans
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit
und wir wollen in Deutschland nicht
länger Knechte der Amerikaner sein wir
wollen nicht Knechte der NATO sein
sondern wir müssen endlich lernen
eigene Interessen zu formulieren zu den
Initiatoren der Kundgebung zählt Markus
Beisicht ein Rechtsanwalt der schon
lange in der Politik aktiv ist nach
Anfängen in der CDU wird ihr Funktionär
rechtsradikaler Gruppen wie der
Republikaner und pro NRW jetzt gehört
bei Sicht zu den Gründern eines
russisch-deutschen Vereins der Name die
Brücke für ihn gehe es um Freundschaft
beider Staaten und einen Gegenpol zur
kremlkritischen deutschen
Berichterstattung es gibt nicht die eine
Wahrheit ich erlebe wenn wir unsere
Medien wir leben da gibt es nur eine
Sicht
da steht man auf der richtige Seite da
gibt es wie in primitiven amerikanischen
Film dass das Gute und das das Böse
schwarz-weiß-töne gibt es nicht das Böse
muss verdammt werden da gibt es alles
schlecht beim Bösen und beim guten ist
alles gut und
jetzt erleben wir eine andere Sicht der
Dinge
die Frage ist sicherlich
berechtigt es gibt natürlich
keinerlei Befehle oder Vorgaben
von Russland oder von anderen Stellen
das also meinen also Engagement
hat sich aus eigenen Schlussfolgerungen
entwickelt
Russland Freunde gibt es aber auch
direkt im Deutschen Bundestag viele sind
Politiker aus den Reihen der AFD die
Stimmung gegen den Westen und die
Ukraine machen
einer von ihnen ist der
afd-bundestagsabgeordnete Eugen Schmitt
wollen die Russen Krieg sicher nicht
ein Statement nur wenige Tage vor dem
Einmarsch der russischen Streitkräfte in
die Ukraine doch den Vorwurf russischer
Propaganda Tätigkeit bestreitet der
Abgeordnete
ja ich kann immer wieder die Beispiele
aus meinem Leben nähen also dass ich als
fünfte Kolone Putins dargestellt wurde
obwohl ich nie über putinspolitik
gesprochen habe ich mich interessierte
diese Politik eigentlich gar nicht
der Facebook-Account des Abgeordneten
zeigt hingegen dieses Bild da werden
westliche Sanktionen von ihm in Frage
gestellt
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
kritisiert vielen ist das selbst in der
AFD zu Russland freundlich mit hingegen
findet auf seinem Facebook-Account
deutliche Worte für Russlands Einmarsch
kurz nach dem Kriegsausbruch
seit 2014 sind tausende Zivilisten im
Donbass getötet worden meist ethnische
Russen das Russland diese Menschen nicht
gleichgültig sein können ist
verständlich
im russischen Staatsfernsehen wird der
afd-politiker zum Kronzeugen angeblicher
deutscher Missstände
selbstverständlich werden die Medien in
Deutschland komplett von der Regierung
kontrolliert Alternative und
Oppositionelle Meinungen sind nicht
vertreten
doch mit russischer Propaganda habe all
das nichts zu tun Schmidt fühlt sich
falsch verstanden ich wurde auch falsch
meistens falsch zitiert also mir wurde
zum Beispiel Zitat vorgeworfen ist in
Deutschland gibt es keine Demokratie und
kein Rechtsstaat mehr das habe ich nicht
gesagt bzw ich habe einfach mal auf
Demokratiedefizite hingewiesen und ich
sehe das als Pflicht auch auf diese
Defizite hinzuweisen
in Russland ist Eugen Schmidt inzwischen
ein populärer Mann weiß
Politologe und gehört zu den
Unterstützern der Vereinigung
journalists in Need sie helfen in Not
geratenen russischen Journalisten
Russland und russische Propaganda
braucht
solche Menschen wie Eugen Schmidt und
durch diese Kommentare
schafft Russland und russische
Propaganda dieses Bild das in
Deutschland die Mehrheit der Menschen
anders denkt das ist eine gezielte
Strategie die Politologe verfolgt die
russische Propaganda insbesondere die
deutschsprachigen Internetangebote für
mediaf sind sie Instrumente Putins im
Kampf gegen westliche Demokratien
das sind keine Medien das sind
Instrumente zu diesen Informationen und
zu die Stabilisierung
die auch im Ausland genutzt werden das
ist eine politische Waffe und spätestens
seit der Annexion der Krims seit 2014
nutzt der Kreml das verstärkt und das
ist eine
ernstzunehmende Gefahr für die
Demokratie in der EU zum
desinformationsprogramm des Kreml
gehören auch eigene Fernsehanstalten der
Fernsehsender Russia Today verfolgt eine
Strategie der Sender wurde vom
russischen Staat ins Leben gerufen mit
einer klaren politischen Vorgabe
der Gründung 2005 hatten wir uns
vorgenommen objektiv über Russland zu
berichten und wir versuchen was ich
betone das Monopol der angelsächsischen
Medien zu brechen
anders was von sexy
inzwischen wurde Russia Today umbenannt
der neue Name schlicht RT
2014 kam der Sender nach Deutschland
nach eigenen Angaben eine unabhängige
Stimme die Europas herrschenden ein Dorn
im Auge sein
jahrelang arbeitete der
investigativjournalist Daniel lange für
den russischen Sender hunderte von
Fernseh Reportagen produzierte er zuvor
für Sat.1 BBC oder weiß dann lockte das
Geld 2016 steigt er bei RT ein
bei Russia Today was natürlich so dass
das Geld verlockend war es waren sehr
hohes Gehalt und kann sich orientieren
an der tagesgarage von ungefähr 1000
Euro pro Tag 700 bis 1000 Euro pro Tag
als als Freiberufler innerhalb der
Produktion
was dann letzten Endes ein Monatsgehalt
als Angestellter ausmachte von über
15.000 Euro brutto
lange sieht in seiner Anstellung ein
Kalkül mit seiner bekannten Handschrift
sollte er RT in Deutschland etablieren
helfen
ging also damit erstmal das Image als
seriösen Sender so weit es geht nach
vorne zu treiben und dafür eben auch
Leute zu finden und zu beschäftigen die
eben auch wissen wie man in
Anführungsstrichen seriöses Fernsehen
macht was den Zuschauer abholt und ihn
auch erreicht daneben gibt es den
propagandaauftrag Berichterstattung in
RT über Pro russische Demonstrationen in
Deutschland
auch machen mit
und wir stehen die machen den Medien
Lügerei die rt-reporterin hat sichtlich
Gefallen an den Parolen
ich danke dir für deine Unterstützung
ich wurde aus meiner heutigen Erfahrung
sagen dass die gesamte Idee Russia to
der beziehungsweise überhaupt dieses
ganze rt-netzwerk auf der Welt
aufzubauen überall den Hintergrund hat
zwischen stabilisieren überall den
erhobenen Zeigefinger hochzuhalten und
überall zu erzählen was jetzt in
Deutschland in unserem Land falsch läuft
es gab keinen nichtsneutrales mehr
lange zieht für sich Konsequenzen 2021
sein Ende bei RT seitdem arbeitet er für
andere Sender
immer lauter und aggressiver wettern die
russischen Auslandssender gegen das
politische System Deutschlands also in
der coronazeit der lockdown-zeit gab es
sehr viele Beiträge natürlich auf RT und
spurte die sich mit der corona-politik
in Westeuropa beschäftigt haben der
Tenor war immer identisch die Regierung
möchte euch klein halten die Wissen auf
der Faschismus die Demokratie geht
verloren lasst euch nicht impfen
nach dem Ukraine Einmarsch kommt der
Sender RT auf die Sanktionsliste der EU
die Begründung RT verfolge eine
systematische Kampagne der
Medienmanipulation mit dem Ziel der
Destabilisierung der Europäischen Union
doch trotz des offiziellen sendeverbots
arbeitet der russische Sender weiter
Russia Today wurde ja im März verboten
und wir finden uns die
Google-Suchanfragen anschauen finden wir
auch die Bemühungen auch im Westen diese
Sperre zu umgehen beispielsweise beim
VPN aber es gibt mittlerweile auch
Dienste wie Odyssey die es gar nicht
mehr erforderlich machen
irgendwelche technischen Tricks
anzuwenden um Russia Today zu empfangen
wer kennt es nicht man will auf die
Webseite von rt.de aber die EU lässt
einen
die russische Propagandamaschine läuft
weiter und lässt sich offensichtlich
auch von der Europäischen Union nicht
aufhalten das Internet macht es möglich
in welchem Umfang der Sender RT das
Verbot umgeht überrascht selbst
ExpertInnen
die Arbeit läuft weiter sie ist sogar
intensiviert es gibt einen Liveticker
zum ukrainekrieg wo man also von morgens
bis abends aktuelle Nachrichten lesen
kann auch das Fernsehprogramm wird
weiter produziert und verbreitet und ich
denke dass es ein Skandal weil wir haben
ja die EU-Sanktionen die die Verbreitung
der RT Inhalte verbietet das ist ein
Skandal das ist nicht durchgesetzt wird
inzwischen wird auch der Ton der
propagandistenrauer bislang richtete
sich ihre Kritik oftmals nur gegen die
Unterstützung des Westens für die
Ukraine jetzt ziehen sie auch gegen das
politische System in Deutschland so wie
hier auf einer Veranstaltung in Köln im
September 2022
und wir müssen aufhören was soll denn
der Amerikaner zu sein und das tun was
die Amerikaner von uns verlangen Frau
Annalena Berger
sie sind eine Gefahr für Europa
treten sie zurück
nehmen sie ihre ganzen Volksverräter mit
treten sie selbst zurück bevor sie vom
Thron gestoßen werden
[Applaus]
und dann spricht ein afd-redner sogar
davon das Russland Deutschland befreien
müsse
und wenn schon Russland die Ukraine von
Nazis befreit dann sollen die auch bei
uns im Bett ringordnung schaffen wenn
wir haben auch die Nazis bei uns sitzen
der Kampf mit Worten wird immer offener
ausgetragen mit einem klaren politischen
Kalkül beobachtet datenanalyst Steven
broscheid
also das Hauptziel der russischen
Propaganda dürfte in erster Linie ja ein
Staat zersetzen in Charakter haben es
wird immer wieder herausgestellt wie
gespalten eigentlich auch die westliche
Gemeinschaft ist also ein ganz
wesentlicher Punkt
Kriegspropaganda Destabilisierung die
Verächtlichmachung der deutschen
Demokratie was kann man dagegen tun auf
Anfrage von zDFzoom erklärt das
Bundesinnenministerium die Verbreitung
von Desinformationen gehöre zu den
großen sicherheitspolitischen
Herausforderungen denen man sich Stelle
bereits kurz nach Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges gegen die Ukraine wurde
eine interministerielle Taskforce
etabliert durch die ein Austausch zur
Erkennung und abwehrhybrider Bedrohungen
insbesondere Desinformation im
Zusammenhang mit Russlands Krieg in der
Ukraine sichergestellt wird
in der Ukraine Rollen Panzer um
Russlands Weltordnung zu erzwingen in
Deutschland versuchen Propagandisten
immer offener die Gesellschaft zu
verunsichern allein mit Verboten ist der
Kampf der Worte offensichtlich nicht zu
gewinnen
Kriegspropaganda muss konsequenter
verfolgt sanktionen müssen durchgesetzt
werden für Deutschlands Demokratie eine
Bewährungsprobe
[Musik]